the Michael Bennett era is over in New
England he's the guy they were obsessed
with stopping in Super Bowl xlix when he
was with the Seahawks he joined the team
this year when he was suspended one game
last week for conduct detrimental to the
team and there was this weird statement
that was issued by him that clearly
wasn't written by him and suggested
there was some sort of an altercation
with his position coach my assessment at
the time big cat was they didn't cut him
on the spot because they didn't want him
to show up with the Ravens or the Chiefs
or the Texans or the bills or any team
they're worried about in the AFC so they
were gonna wait until after the trade
deadline to cut him when he would have
to pass through waivers or they're gonna
trade him to an NFC team and lo and
behold one day after he had some
comments to the media that suggested he
wasn't all that thrilled with what's
going on in New England he's traded to
the Dallas Cowboys for a sixth round
pick or a seventh round pick in 2021
they basically gave the guy a way to get
him out of the AFC and now he's the
Cowboys problem and the Cowboys will
hope that they can push the buttons on
him and somehow get the most out of him
because they could use some help in that
pass rush rotation in Dallas well I
think the Cowboys will be able to get
something out of him because the Cowboys
don't employ my good old friend Bret
Bielema I think that's where the the
issues arose right wasn't it Bret
Bielema versus Michael Bennett and that
was where things will started to go
south either way that's a nice trade for
the Cowboys because they get them for
basically nothing and we also get the
Michael Bennett revenge game coming up I
love when we get a revenge game from a
guy who was on a team for like two weeks
that's what's gonna happen when the
Cowboys play the Patriots later in the
season November 24 that's the big Sunday
game before the Cowboys play the bills
on Thanksgiving and there's a chance
Bennett's not even the roster by then
although I think the Cowboys will look
the other way to try to get the good
Michael Bennett the Michael Bennett that
we saw those years in Seattle who was so
dominant who would who would destroy the
play on a regular basis he was kind of
like that in Philadelphia but not to the
same extent and in New England he just
wasn't good enough
to deal with the headaches and his his
greatest hits big cat you'll like this
when he was with Seattle at one point
they played the Lions and this was four
years ago
Michael Bennett made it clear he doesn't
like Matthew Stafford and he explained
after the game
I don't like Matthew Stafford very much
he's from Dallas
they killed JFK so so now Michael
Bennett is playing in Dallas should make
for an interesting introductory press
conference if someone decides to remind
him that he's now playing for the city
that he hates because they killed JFK 60
years ago I like that let's bring up
some old history he also this is also a
bookend for the been approached because
remember
Martellus started as a Dallas Cowboy in
there from Texas so maybe a mini
homecoming even though he doesn't like
Dallas because the whole JFK thing I
didn't know the city of Dallas killed
JFK but an interesting quote to bring
back up I like that my good job way to
do your research Cowboys find themselves
still making headlines even when they
are on a bye and there one of the two
teams on a bye this week the Dallas
Cowboys and the Baltimore Ravens and the
Cowboys after getting that win on Sunday
night 27 to 10 they probably wish they
were playing again this weekend to add
to that momentum I mean I think the
Cowboys can still be a force in the NFC
last year they were three and five when
they played the Eagles on Sunday Night
Football won that game they went seven
and one down the stretch three and three
this year when they play the Eagles and
beat the Eagles
you know they go on a run here it
doesn't take much if they can just
string wins together it doesn't take
much to find yourself in a position
where you're competing for a first round
by big cat
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports